what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so it's been god it's been a while
since we've done a character explanation
it's been a long time really it's
because I just kind of got burned out on
it we did those non-stop for like two
years and I was like yeah I'm ready to
do something else besides just new
character explanations all the time he
was job me crazy but daredevil season 3
is coming out and the main enemy of that
season of this coming season is bull's
eye so I figured why not do a character
explanation on the character of bullseye
now here's the thing and this is one of
those this is one of those
misconceptions that drives me up the
wall people always say that bull's eye
made his appearance or really made his
debut in Marvel Comics back in 1976 with
daredevil 131 that's not true he
actually made his appearance back in
1969 with Nick Fury agent of shield and
that was a story by gary friedrich herd
for a herb shrimp and dick airs those
you guys don't know who they are
not a great big huge deal but there's a
couple differences there so the original
version of bullseye back in the old
assassination of Nick Fury story he was
called bullseye
so it wasn't like all one word you had a
hyphen in there so his bu LLS - I and
then he looked a little bit different
but aside from those things he was still
basically the same he was a prodigious
assassin he was highly skilled in
killing people and so for the most part
everything was the same but seven years
later in 1976 you ended up having Marv
Wolfman who rolled him over into the
daredevil comics now the reason why was
because back in 1964 when daredevil
first showed up he was hugely popular
because he was basically a street-level
character who was blind and who had like
you know enhanced see enhanced senses
through echolocation things like that
and it struck a chord with readers for a
momentary point in time the issue was
that Marvel in the 1960s was literally
like a frantic madhouse of just
introducing characters and teams as it
was like if you have an idea put it on
paper we'll send it out if we're not
gonna trust it with a solo series we'll
throw it in an anthology series and call
it a day and that was like all over the
place and so by the time you got to the
late nineteen really the early 1970s
even to the mid-1970s characters who
were street-level basically almost
anyone except for like spider-man
weren't really interesting anymore
people had already picked their
favorites you had x-men which was
regaining popularity because of Chris
Claremont you had Fantastic Four which
is already popular The Avengers you had
Captain America because it's Captain
America and so they really kind of had
their there solid base of what Marvel
knew would sell and so the result was
that momma wasn't really willing to
cancel daredevil so much is just like
shift the writers around all the time so
Marv Wolfman to come on board and he
actually wrote between issues like 125
and 139 I think it was
then he wrote a couple issues in the
140s and that was about it but his idea
was just tell different stories about
daredevil and see if there's a way to
make it work and so for the most part it
didn't it didn't work it didn't work all
that well the bullseye was there and he
his debut came in issues 131 and 132 or
at least from our wolf win anyway caiman
issues 131 and 132 and all that you
really find out about him is that he's
just a really skilled assassin any
challenges daredevil to see whether or
not he can defeat the guy and make a
name for himself now ultimately ends up
getting defeated but as a guy who
managed to stand a pretty significant
chance against daredevil himself he does
pretty well now this goes into this goes
into his origin stories which are are
pretty iffy the most notable one comes
with uh with bull's eye greatest hits
number one back from 2004 and it's
pretty straight forward
uh he's just basically a guy who's Alesi
claims that his brothers had fire to
their home and he made it out alive but
his dad died and that kind of a thing
but it's one of those things where they
kind of pull of Killing Joke sort a
situation where it's like actually none
of its true and but in both sides the
one who says it it's not true at all so
there is no definitive origin for his
character it's just kind of a hodgepodge
of different things and you can take
like the three or four origins that he
has and take them for what they're worth
but after losing a daredevil
but successfully holding his own this
eventually goes into his involvement
with regards to really becoming more of
like a daredevil character now this was
not something that happened overnight
right it wasn't as oh he was introduced
in 131 and then just went on to become a
daredevil mainstay instead what you had
is you had issues 160 and 161 which were
written by Roger McKenzie and then you
had issue 169 which was done by Dennis
O'Neil and those began to sort of segue
bullseye into more of like a mainstay
for daredevil character he wasn't by any
means like a great big huge guy but one
of the notable things that he did
actually two great big huge things he
did the first one was in the Roger
McKenzie run when he kidnapped Black
Widow and the second was in the Dennis
O'Neil run when Dennis O'Neil came back
and said actually the reason why
bullseye loves killing people is because
he has a tumor and he's basically
psychotic because of his tumor now the
move with Black Widow
was actually pretty well-received and it
was a pretty cool thing because at the
time
Black Widow was still being fleshed out
in Marvel Comics I mean you know she
originally appeared as a villain a hawk
I had been tricked into becoming her
aide and then eventually he turned Kody
became a good guy and eventually Black
Widow became a good guy but uh but at
the time Marvel was still trying to like
shuffler around and figure out what they
wanted to do but there was enough fan
interest there that the idea of bullseye
kidnapping Black Widow and then
daredevil having to rescue her and
defeat
yet again was enough to pique interest
even if only a little bit the idea of
him having a tumor and that's the reason
why he's insane
bullseye fans hated that they did not
like the idea behind it because their
whole concept was he really is just a
crazy guy but he's also just that good
because what it did is that opened the
door for the possibility that Marvel
could reduce his ability to be accurate
and then say well once he was cured of
his tumor he's not as accurate as he
used to be and fans were afraid mother
would take certain liberties ultimately
they didn't and this actually segue
directly into Frank Miller's run and
that's the important thing here is
because when Dennis O'Neil was riding
daredevil when Roger McKenzie was riding
daredevil it was actually Frank Miller
who was drawing it or at least drew a
few issues here in there and so once
Frank Miller took over as the actual
writer that changed everything because
again at the time daredevil was like by
that point in time when Frank Miller
took over Dirt Devil was struggling I
mean you almost couldn't give his comics
away because there's been a few
interviews of people have done and a lot
of people have drawn the conclusion that
at the end of the day because of how his
character was written because of the
narratives that were given because of
the direction of the art and so on that
really all daredevil came down to was
like a Spider Man clone as a result was
that people just kind of said well if
I'm gonna read spider-man that I'll just
go read spider-man and so that you know
among other things you know the fall of
characters like Iron Fist
and Luke Cage they're they're they're
dropping popularity it was one of those
things where street-level characters are
basically beginning to die out and so
enter Frank Miller now Frank Miller's
take on daredevil this is something a
lot of people don't know Frank Miller's
take on daredevil almost didn't happen
and the reason why was because where you
had Roger McKenzie who was writing it at
one point and then you had did so Neil
who was writing it at one point with
Frank Miller doing a lot of the art work
he hated the scripts of Roger
Mackenzie's well he considered them to
be absolutely terrible and there was one
point where he almost quit because the
sales just weren't improving anymore but
eventually Dennis O'Neill went on to be
editor I went on to become
editor-in-chief reigai I think editor
but he went on to a higher ranking
position within Marvel and then actually
appointed Frank Miller to become the
writer for the stories and so when that
happened everything shifted entirely
because now Frank Miller looked at Roger
Mackenzie's work and said this is
basically work going nowhere if we're
gonna take street-level superheroes or
street-level characters and we're gonna
make them characters that people like
then we have to start making them darker
we have to start giving people a reason
to want to read them and so Frank Miller
basically took the entire concept of
daredevil and turned it on its head
bull's eye was part and parcel to that
and that's where people make the mistake
the whole idea of bullseye killing
Elektra was not rooted in making
bullseye more interesting he was a means
to an end
it was rooted in making daredevil much
much darker and so the way this played
out
originally was that on the line between
Roger McKenzie and Dennis O'Neal's run
as well as a couple runs before there's
especially in Marv Wolfman there came a
point where bull's eye was basically a
henchman working for kingpin now the
issue with this was that he eventually
ran to daredevil tried to implement a
scheme was busted and sent to jail
and so what Frank Miller did is he used
that as a way to not really write
bull's-eye out of the picture but to
replace him and then set up the means
for bullseye to make daredevil a darker
character the way that this played out
was that following the imprisonment of
bullseye Elektra was introduced Elektra
had been introduced in in 168 1981 and
that she actually became a lover of
daredevil and so the weight of this
played out was bull's eye had basically
managed to escape prison after realizing
that a lecture was the number one
assassin of kingpin and then in turn
killed Elektra
but kingpin actually ordered bullseye to
cure kill daredevil if he was looking
for a return to his position if those so
in response to this bullseye actually
tracked down and I'm sorry on either
bullseye track down daredevil or data
will track him down I want to say bull's
eye was the one who tracked down
daredevil a fight initiated and then
daredevil actually broke his back he
broke his spine like shattered the whole
thing and so this this allowed for Frank
Miller to make daredevil a lot more a
lot darker and a lot more screwed up
when it got to daredevil 191 which is
actually one of the most popular issues
of his character and the way that this
played out the way that this happened is
you ended up having a bull's-eye who is
recovering in a hospital from his
injuries from daredevil when daredevil
broke in brought a revolver and then
sort of playing a game of Russian
Roulette it's actually one of the most
one of the most dark moments for his
character and it's super twisted but
also super amazing because when
daredevil breaks in there and starts
interrogating bullseye bullseye thinks
the guns loaded and Daredevil's just
like we're playing a game of Russian
Roulette and that's just the way it goes
and it's and it's kind of nuts and so it
was a little more than like bull's eye
could handle and the way the Frank
Miller really kind of concluded this was
intending to write bull's eye out to
basically say like that's the end of his
character or at least with regards to
the Frank Miller run because you don't
really hear from from bull's eye again
after that and so following this you end
up jumping into daredevil vol 2 now for
the most part you don't really see
bull's eye that much in daredevil vol 2
he's just kind of there he just like
occasionally pops up in reality this
really marked one of the one of the not
really as good as frame Miller's but
like it's still one of the pretty solid
runs that came with foe okay with
someone by the name of an miss NT now
where M Masson T's run was notable for
introducing characters like typhoid mary
who's probably one of the most I were
the most
interesting of the daredevil villains
her involvement with bullseye was fairly
limited in the sense that you had issues
284 to 291 I think it was which actually
had somewhat of an identity crisis where
you ended up having daredevil who left
you had bullseye who took up the
daredevil mantle and then sort of
believing he was daredevil and then
daredevil took up the bullseye mantle
and the two of them fought which kind of
you know brought bullseye back to his
senses you know so to speak but
nonetheless um from there it really just
kind of picks up into him going out and
it's really sort of fluctuating around
and free-floating in the Marvel Comics
universe and the reason why I say that
is because again outside of his
involvement in the death of electric
bullseye was just kind of a villain who
was there and nobody ever really knew
what to do with him and so when you go
and look at like Chuck Dixon's Punisher
run for example issues 101 to 102 he has
a part in that story are you start going
and looking at like future stories that
are written later on down the line you
look at like daredevil vol 2 a forty
eight through 49 which I think was
written by Kevin Smith he's just kind of
there and and just sort of free-floating
around and just does a few things here
and there he's contracted by like
Mysterio things like that but nothing
too significant he just kind of occupies
a place and this really segues and goes
all the way up to the events of Civil
War
when he finally gets a home so to speak
and the reason for this was because
during the events of Civil War one of
the things that Marvel had done which is
actually really interesting was make a
super villain team something akin to
their own Suicide Squad but not exactly
the way this played out was you had of
course Tony Stark and Captain America
who were essentially fighting against
one another you know kind of splitting
the superhero community down the middle
but with regards to Iron Man the entire
superhero landscape was in shambles you
had the Mighty Avengers who existed to
track down various superheroes but then
you also had their need to be able to
access the criminal element of the
Marvel Universe and so what they did is
they brought together a team called a
thunderbolt which was led by helmet Zemo
Baron helmet Zima the son of Baron Zemo
and man was basically filled with like
your your PRNDL ik rim so to speak of
like the various villains and Marvel
kind of like the unsellable the ones who
couldn't really hold a book and who were
just kind of free-floating out there and
I really knew what to do with I think
Norman Osborn played a role but the fact
remains that you ended up having like
the thunderbolts going forward and like
rounding up vigilante heroes and so on
and so forth the cool thing about this
was that for the various scripts that
were written with the various stories
that were done really with the whole
Thunderbolts concept you ended up having
like like Warren Ellis and others who
really kind of built on the idea that
bullseye was crazy that bullseye was
absolutely bonkers that he loved killing
people and used that as a means to kind
of make his character a little more diff
and what I mean by that is what they
would do is they would have him continue
to go on these missions with you know
the Thunderbolts and so on and so forth
but he was always kind of treated like
the Joker like he was absolutely
sadistic if he was allowed to just go
off on his own reins and do his own
thing he would kill everybody that he
came across and so they were basically
keep him shackled up shut away from
everybody else in addition to this
because Civil War went directly into the
events of Secret Invasion that's when
you ended up seeing a bull's-eye along
with a handful of others end up
defeating you know some of the scrolls
and and so on but again he's just kind
of there he's just kind of free-floating
he plays these these roles where he kind
of spikes up and drops down and his
spikes up and drops down but that's
about it there was never one of those
things where he ever achieved the same
level of popularity or the same
significance that he had during Frank
Miller's run at least not into the
events of Dark Reign now Dark Reign is
when a lot of things shifted up for
bull's eye and for a lot of the villains
that were out there and the reason for
this is because going from from civil
war to secret invasion to Dark Reign
itself what ended up happening here in
this sort of really the the middle road
the halfway mark er of joke Asada's like
reinvention of Marvel Comics you ended
up having Norman Osborn who intervened
information that would allow the
superheroes to defeat the scrolls and
then passed it off as though it was his
idea that in turn led to the u.s.
government telling Tony Stark that he
was ineffective as director of shield
because he didn't know Secret Invasion
was happening they kicked him out they
replace him with Norman Osborn and
Norman Osborn basically dismantled
shield created hammer and then when
almost all the superheroes evacuated
bailed out and went underground then
that led directly into the Dark Avengers
and really like the dark dark x-men and
dr. superhero teams it was away from
Marvel to shift things up so that
instead of having like your Avengers
your Mighty Avengers your your x-men and
so on and so forth that you could have
villains playing those characters and so
for a bull's-eye he was shifted up and
he became the character of Hawkeye so he
was kind of like the dark version of
Hawkeye himself which is kind of cool I
mean he had run-ins with like the
century like the the stories themselves
in terms of what they did were not that
significant the Dark Avengers had a
couple good stories but they would do
things like fight you know if I nonsense
stuff you know robots and different
things like that
and it was it was all right for what it
was but there did come a point it's
actually one of the coolest parts of the
story they did come a point and Deadpool
volume three issue number 12 where he
actually faces off against Deadpool
again and the reason why that matters
and the reason why it's kind of cool is
because that actually shifts it really
kind of jumps back really to a story
from I want to say was Deadpool vol 1
with Joe Kelly were you actually
defining out that that bullseye had
adamantium laced to his bones by Lord
darkman in order to be
more effective assassin whatever the
reason was and of course that's what he
faced off against dead pull at one point
but that kind of established the idea
between these two stories it laid out
the idea that bullseye and Deadpool had
actually teamed up on a multitude of
occasions back when Deadpool before Joe
Kelly took him over and he became
comedic back when Rob - was writing the
stories and Deadpool was like a
straight-up assassin like a straight-up
killer for hire the two of them will
work together they they had been you
know teammates that were really allies
for a little while then eventually
became enemies and and so on and so
forth but things were just kind of
shifting around and that goes into
things like siege it goes into shadow
land it goes into like a lot of these
stories and running all the way up until
all-new all-different marvel when he
basically ends up ends up losing his
eyesight from from daredevil and he's
just kind of trapped inside of his own
body but it's a cool situation because
what it does is it allowed mauville to
kind of shift the character around and
move them around throw them in weird
different positions and see if they
would all work at the end of the day but
I would say and this is one of the
coolest things for people who are
daredevil fans and this is hopefully
something will see in daredevil season 3
I would say that one of the most
significant moments of bullseye outside
of his hem killing a lecture during
Frank Miller's run came during the
events of shadow land now for those who
guys who don't know shadow land was a
story where daredevil was possessed by
like the Great Beast of the hand and
floating I don't know the hand what is
an organization that dates back decades
you know thousands of thousands of years
and we need to go through the whole
thing but they they were really hundreds
of years they go back quite a ways but
there was one point in the very very
early days of humanity that the group
that would later on become the hand had
worshipped this you know demonic entity
of sorts and it was kind of like their
God so to speak well eventually that God
takes possession of Matt Murdock who in
turn takes control of the hand and so
he's basically this villain sitting
inside shadow land in the middle of
Hell's Kitchen New York and just like
running this massive criminal empire and
so there comes a point when bullseye
basically travels to try to fight
daredevil and says look like I want you
like I want to I want it like I want to
take you out daredevil comes out with a
veritable army of the hand and bull's
eye defeats them all and then goes on to
fight daredevil now of course he ends up
getting beat by daredevil because of all
the advanced abilities he has because
he's possessed but successfully
defeating multiple ninjas of the hand
that was designed for the purpose of
saying that like bull's eye is not just
a guy who's there he's a guy who's a
legit incredible threat because for
those who have been reading Marvel
Comics the hand or no joke they are
deadly as hell if somebody contracts the
hand to come after you then you better
have your affairs in order and that's
just all there is to analyse your
Wolverine spider-man unless your Spider
Woman Jessica drew or like more
lafha there's nothing you're gonna be
able to do to stop the hand from getting
to you so successfully like defeating a
few dozen of them by himself is no small
feat and that's one of the things that
like a lot of a lot of bullseye fans
kind of champion is one of the great
moments of his character when he was
literally able to rip things apart now
again it's kind of interesting to see
what they're gonna do with this
character it is Netflix so it's gonna be
a lot more grounded than we're used to
it's not gonna be as near nearly as like
far flung and and crazy but I do think
we might see things like him defeating
the hand of course we'll see him going
toe-to-toe with daredevil and we'll
certainly see like some pretty crazy
stuff in terms of being super accurate
with stuff I wonder if we're gonna see
the one that we saw from like that
terrible ben affleck deadpool move I'm
sorry bullseye a daredevil movie from
back in the day where bull's-eyes
introduced and he actually ends up
throwing like what what does it he did
hit through paper clips into a guy's
neck and killed him I were never gonna
see stuff like that because in the
comics he's done crazy things like that
like there was one point he threw a
toothpick a hundred yards and killed a
guy like I mean it's nuts the kind of
stuff that this guy can do and it's
absolutely bonkers there was one point
where he threw a paper I'm pretty sure
he threw a paper airplane with such
accuracy with such an incredible
accuracy that like it flew all the way
to another building unlike the other
side of not really the other side of
town but like a pretty good distance
like it was it's pretty crazy in terms
of the kind of stuff he's able to do
it's a little bonkers in terms of the
stuff that he can then he can pull off
but nonetheless you know I'm curious to
see what we're gonna get I'm curious to
see how the whole thing is gonna unfold
I'm pretty excited about it but yeah we
got being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
too comments explained make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]